[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette vidéo que les devoirs c'est la
réaction d'un petit garçon de 2 ans la
première fois que je les années dans un
camp de réfugiés en grèce et comme vous
pouvez le voir sa réaction ça a été
d'aller à la rencontre de l'autre n'en
avait rien à faire de la couleur de leur
peau de leur religion leur nationalité
il a juste vu d'autres êtres humains
avec lesquels ils pouvaient jouer et
interagir et je trouve que c'est
intéressant de comparer sa réaction à
celles qu'on peut voir en europe depuis
quelques années de pic il ya ce qu'on
appelle la crise migratoire
on a vu plus tôt la défiance voire même
de la haine
alors la haine c'est un sentiment
intéressant parce que ça déjà c'est un
sentiment humain
les animaux ne lisent pas les animaux
chasse pour se nourrir c'est défendent
mais pas de haine et en même temps on
voit bien que la haine
on n'est pas avec suffit de regarder mon
fils sur cette vidéo
et pourtant si on fait tous un petit
travail d'introspection
on peut voir qu'on en a un petit peu en
nous qu'on en a eu à des moments à doha
ou à d'autres la haine elle a un spectre
extrêmement large ça va de la haine
génocidaire elles sont maxima mais a
minima c'est juste de penser que mon
groupe est un peu supérieure un autre
groupe ou que j'ai pas très envie
d'interagir avec un autre groupe
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que les motifs de la haine ils sont
créés par un contexte ceux qui haïssent
pense qu'ils ont des raisons
rationnelles de le faire mais ce n'est
pas le cas
que ce soit à auschwitz à ferguson à
christchurch à toulouse ou à paris ces
raisons elles ont été créées par le
contexte il faut que quelqu un produit à
un moment donné dans un cadre historique
dans une certaine culture
les motifs dont se prévaut la haine
et qui expliquerait qu'un groupe de la
population mériterait cette haine et ses
raisons ensuite il faut qu'elle soit
énoncée répéter illustré encore et
encore jusqu'à ce qu'elle se sédimente
en couche épaisse dans nos esprits les
ne peuvent énuméré les raisons de leur
haine des réfugiés par exemple mais ces
raisons ne sont pas la cause de leurs m
simplement ils ont décidé qu'un certain
nombre de qualités sa tribu et à tous
les réfugiés et que ses qualités sont
jugé méprisable haïssable dangereuses et
pourtant si on écoute deux minutes
ces raisons on voit bien qu'elles sont
absolument pas rationnel les réfugiés on
leur reprochait à la fois de venir en
france pour bénéficier des minima
sociaux et à la fois de venir voler le
travail des bons français ça n'a pas de
sens
et justement c'est un des mécanismes
clés de la haine c'est la diminution de
la place de la réalité regardez le
traitement médiatique qui est fait des
musulmans au mieux ce sont des barbares
un culte aux pires des terroristes et
pour les réfugiés c'est pareil on en
parle toujours comme d'un groupe comme
10 était homogène sans jamais parler des
individus et ce qu'il faut réaliser
c'est que à partir du moment où on leur
on les regarde comment ni à l'autre sa
qualité de prochain on se donne la
possibilité de haïr ce groupe c'est un
processus de déshumanisation
on y au réfugiés leur qualité d'être
humain
le fait qu'ils ont une histoire qu'ils
ont une expérience et qu'ils ont des
qualités spécifiques et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il ya quelques années avec
mon associé qui est un photographe
portugais qui s'appelle josé farinia on
a lancé un projet qui s'appelle biodis
et project est donc ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on va rencontrer des réfugiés en
europe et au moyen-orient mais des
réfugiés conte des histoires positives
des gens qui sont entrepreneurs comme
imad qui est un grand chef syrien
des artistes comme olga qui est
professeur de danse des bénévoles comme
une âme qui est sherman d'une
association en suède et qui s'occupent
d'un camp de réfugiés ont les interviews
on les prend en photo on raconte leur
histoire sur notre site internet et sur
les réseaux sociaux
'cependant un des voyages que j'ai faits
pour dieu disait project que j'ai
rencontré ce qui pour moi restera
l'image de la haine c'est mohamed qui
m'a raconté son histoire
mohamed c'est un réfugié palestinien qui
vit dans le camp de aida à côté de
bethléem un jour alors qu'il travaillait
dans une association il est directeur de
l'unité médias parce qu'il est
journaliste et photoreporter il a
entendu des militaires israéliens passer
devant les locaux de l'association
rentrer dans le camp de aïda et au bout
de quelques heures en ressortir et il
tirait des coups de feu et donc mohamed
a fait son travail c'est à dire qu'il
est sorti sur le balcon de l'association
il a pris des photos
parce qu'ils devaient documenté cet
événement et au bout d'un moment
un militaire a tiré dans sa direction
c'était une mise en garde est sagement
il a décidé de rentrer à l'intérieur de
l'immeuble
il s'est juste pencher
pour refermer la porte coulissante et à
ce moment là un des militaires lui a
tiré une balle dans sa pommette droite
vous pouvez le voir sur la photo on voit
bien la cicatrice et au moment de
l'impact
mohamed a poussé un cri de douleur et
terreur et à ce moment là les cinq
militaires ont ri
et on se demande comment c'est possible
d'en arriver là c'est la haine qui fait
ça c'est ce processus de déshumanisation
dont je vous parlais et pourtant on voit
bien qu'à partir du moment où les ne se
rendent coupables parce que oui c'est
une culpabilité de ce processus de
déshumanisation c'est eux qui perdent
leur humanité dans nos sociétés modernes
il ya deux facteurs d'aggravation de la
haine
le premier c'est le facteur identitaire
l'obsession identitaire est un facteur
aggravant des discours haineux des actes
haineux qu'il soit misogyne homophobe
antisémites racistes
dis moi qui tu es je te dirai qui tu es
cette équation terrible propage l'idée
qu'on ne peut affirmer notre identité
que par la détestation de l'autre et que
si je ne sais pas a lire alors je suis
très très celle ci
le fantasme identitaire repose sur cette
culture de l'ennemi et tous les leaders
populistes qui émerge ici ou là dans le
monde joue justement sur cette haine le
deuxième facteur c'est internet
parce que la haine c'est faire du clic
les discours haineux sont surexposés
parce qu'ils font su réagir
le but étant de collecter un maximum de
nos données personnelles
ils ont besoin de nos interactions or si
je vois un discours haineux sur internet
si je trouve légitime il ya de fortes
chances que j'ai interagissent et si je
le trouve illégitime il ya également de
fortes chances que j'interagis ce
l'ignorance mène à la peur la peur mène
à la haine et la haine conduit à la
violence
voilà l'équation c'est une citation du
12e siècle qui nous donne un début de
piste pour comprendre comment lutter
contre la haine
il faut lutter déjà contre l'ignorance
et quel meilleur moyen pour lutter
contre l'ignorance que les mots il faut
parler il faut écrire il faut
sensibiliser il faut lire si le langage
est pauvre il perd sa valeur de symbole
ief iccat heures
les mots sont des symboles qui nous
permettent de prendre des distances avec
nos pulsions imaginez un média qui ne
parleraient de chrétiens que pour parler
des crimes qu'ils commettent des
scandales pédophiles des attaques
terroristes du ku klux klan des
manifestations violentes contre
l'avortement
vous voyez comment ça changerait notre
perspective c'est un levier énorme et
c'est pour ça que c'est la
responsabilité des intellectuels et des
artistes de réinventer notre rapport au
langage et à l'image il faudra compter
les histoires des individus et c'est
exactement ce qu'on fait avec brio 10 et
project est d'ailleurs à cette occasion
j'ai rencontré des militants contre lem
formidable que ce soit des militants
pacifistes palestiniens qui promeuvent
la solution à un état ou bien que ce
soit cette association au liban qui
s'appelle souk al tayeb et qui utilise
la cuisine pour faire se rencontrer les
communautés alors que le liban est un
pays extrêmement communautariste
il ya des tensions dans certaines
régions qui sont énormes
ils ont réussi à faire cuisiner ensemble
une femme dont le mari avait été
assassiné par le mari d'une autre femme
vous voyez ce qu'on peut faire avec de
la cuisine c'est parce que ces deux
personnes se sont rencontrés c'est
incroyable ce qu'on peut faire
également des initiatives fabuleuse en
france action emploi réfugiés singh à ce
que fait le maire de grande synthe
depuis des années sans aucun soutien
gouvernemental ce qui se passe également
à la frontière italo-française dans les
alpes il y a des gens qui font des
choses incroyables
cédric et rouen tête malgré le
harcèlement judiciaire dont il est le la
victime également ce village dans la
creuse où il ya 200 personnes qui se
sont opposées à la déportation danse ou
d'années de 21 ans il suit à ça il a
obtenu le droit d'asile de la préfecture
toutes ces petites victoires du social
ce sont des résistances
il faut bien qu'on se rendre compte que
dans 20 ans dans trente ans quand la
crise migratoire sera terminé il y aura
des musées qui raconteront ce qui s'est
passé qui raconteront les dizaines des
centaines de milliers de morts dans la
méditerranée dans nos montagnes dans nos
centres villes
il y aura des objets qui ont appartenu à
ces hommes et à ces femmes à ses enfants
qu'est-ce que nous répondrons aux
questions de nos enfants et nos petits
enfants qu'ils demanderont ce qu'on a
fait moi quand je suis devenue maman je
me suis fixé une double mission
la première c'était de faire de mon fils
un être humain des sens parce que c'est
important la décence
la deuxième
c'est de lui apprendre le bonheur je
suis pas particulièrement doué mais j'ai
compris deux trois trucs quand même une
de ces choses c'est que si on est et ne
peut pas être heureux c'est antinomique
on peut pas être serein quand on est
neuf et la haine on en a tous des
petites graines en nous et on peut
choisir de les cultiver au contraire de
les abandonner et je vous propose deux
solutions pour ça la toute première ce
que j'ai fait a glissé project c'est
d'aller à la rencontre de l'autre parce
que quand l'autre nous raconte son
histoire
quand on découvre ses peurs et ses rêves
on peut pas le détester c'est un miroir
c'est la grande histoire de l'humanité
la deuxième solution je vous propose
c'est une technique de méditation qui
s'appelle metab evanna je veux demander
de fermer vos yeux
tous deux vous concentrer sur votre
respiration d'inspirer calmement par le
nez d'expirer lentement vers le nez
et une fois que le bruit mental est
calme et d'essayer de sentir si vous
avez narines et boucher si vous respirez
mieux du narines ou de l'autre de sentir
le flux des respirations juste au dessus
de la lèvre supérieure et ensuite je
vais vous demander de penser à quelqu'un
avec qui vous avez des difficultés
penser à cette personne qui est
difficile pour vous qui peut-être vous a
fait du tort essayez d'imaginer
maintenant ce que ses amis aiment tant
cette personne essayer de penser à ses
qualités
elle en a évidemment maintenant essayer
de prendre un petit peu de recul sur la
situation
essayez de penser peut-être à vos
propres erreurs dans cette relation
d'avoir un regard un peu plus juste
maintenant je vais vous demander
d'essayer de lui souhaiter du bien de
lui souhaiter d'être heureuse et essayer
d'étendre ce sentiment à tous les êtres
vivants
c'était la meilleure chose que vous
pouviez faire aujourd'hui pour vous le
même et pour le monde
vous avez cultivées en vous des graines
de bienveillance et ça va permettre à
tout le monde de vivre plus en harmonie
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]